hi JB JB Smoove just walked in yours
look so good evenin I've seen you in the
morning quite a few times other radio
shows in here and you you always look
really really well-dressed and like
you're ready to be on TV you have no
problem to call me now get up early one
morning take it away I shopping will
walk around go get you I've seen you
look great you see me wins we got a
great photo together of us both in soups
lean against the wall you know of course
we're twice as tall as you are
oh good you still look nice that was in
was that Vegas I remember that would
sound like weird award show like so and
we look fabulous together you know some
about the balance of my chocolate skin
that's right my alabaster tone your
alabaster toned that kind of worked it
did was a nice background
how would you dress dress Jim unlike a
day-to-day basis you can't wear a suit
every day right I think I would I think
I think as far as Howard dress him as a
normal I would I would I would get out
and I would work my way out of the
t-shirts right not all at one time right
gradual a gradual change from the
typical grungy t-shirt look mm-hmm but I
would like you know I will add one
collar at a time nice not a fool in
collar one side dumb [ __ ] you don't like
a one collar but they're gonna look at
them they're gonna notice them right
conversation piece right and then you
add another column you know it's kind of
grown a beard in you know people or
changing your your gray hair back to you
know back to dark you know do it
gradually a grass has to be a transition
transition so someone's seeing you every
day doesn't notice they will notice that
well you can bed say about hair pieces
if you're bald-headed on Wednesday then
that joke by Sinbad you can't get why
would you you're [ __ ] young Steve
Martin his hairpiece is receding that's
the genius
no one's gonna question I guess ago is
got a receding hairline it's a piece oh
yeah big piece Jim is a dashing fellow I
think
with a half a collar I know wouldn't
they think he was an oddball they don't
look at him right
and once they look at you yeah you got
him yeah I see they wouldn't notice his
ass if he didn't have one collar right
you know or even a cut off you don't got
to be a cut-off sheep right
you know you're saying it's like
peacocking like it fit to have a collar
if they look that's all that matters
certain people just need they need
something in their life to catch the
attention of other people breaking on me
like ticks this is a terrible example
but you drive crazy as hell so you get
pulled the [ __ ] over
see uh-huh is that easy so if you walk
crazy you do crazy [ __ ] lady's gonna
pull you over they don't say hey hi hey
what are you doing this guy's
interesting cuz why you wearing that hat
the word eccentric you look good in
clothes some guys look good and clothes
some guys don't you just have a face in
a shape that you just look good in
clothes and if I wore that hat I'd look
like a [ __ ] a sick five-year-old
[Laughter]
don't worry about me right now you can't
wear another this year I talked about
other things like one collar and little
things that you can do to help yourself
is there anything you put on that you're
like I I just look stupid in that
there's got to be something you try on
that you know I just don't like myself
in that see here's how you got a pink
you gotta think I'm not wearing these
[ __ ] clothes these clothes are
wearing me that's how you had a big
night see I got layers on today man
that's my season winter I'm a winter
baby so this is my [ __ ] right here I
love a good scarf a good [ __ ] hat see
I wanna go to the airport and take 15
minutes to take one ever do a wardrobe
change like on your way out of security
oh yeah change sometime you do or I'll
rewrap my scarf a different way I mean
whatever it takes man it's smart you
like looking good hit attend yourself
you gotta look good why the [ __ ] not
when you roll when you a grown-ass man
right take time to look good for your
[ __ ] self there's no sense in you
grunge in the [ __ ] around I know you
don't want to impress yourself but some
gotta get up look in the mirror and try
to impress himself you gotta walk around
as yourself all [ __ ] day why not
impress the dude in the mirror once in a
[ __ ] Wow when did you develop your
your sense of personal style if I always
been dad I've never seen my father where
I passed [ __ ] ever huh ever
I never he passed away but I never see
my dad wear a pair of sneakers just
flip-flop oh cool puppy shoes I know a
lot of white people you guys wear
flip-flops a [ __ ] lot but we never
seen a wear a pair of what if he was
doing something athletic or you know
matter Johnny no matter anymore anyways
shoe boots the shoe boots you know that
means you know come to the ankle all
right [ __ ] you or what he do just a
ritalin job you know regular job but
I've never if he wore work boots or he
wore dress shoes all the time he always
wore dress a nice dress shirt always
wore glasses so this right here you see
me wear my glasses huh
I'm paying homage to my dad it's all
that's all he did what glasses all the
[ __ ] time I saw him in the shower one
time to the shoes were cool cuz every
kid thinks sneakers are cool same a lot
always loved cool ass [ __ ] like all I
loved when I was growing up was watching
James Bond movies and [ __ ] like that the
[ __ ] Avengers and [ __ ] like that with
that [ __ ] umbrella and I got them top
hat yeah I love that kind of the style
of it the style of it I mean I'm telling
you right now I know I'm just a black
man from North Carolina who was born in
North Carolina I still consider myself
very European I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened to me but somewhere in my DNA
you know my middle name is Angelo so
haha where my family you know there's
italiano I'm Italian
somewhere am I in my DNA it's Italian
people my middle name is Angelo you like
to appear as a gentleman you got damn
right man why what [ __ ] that does it I
should step up I'm lazy I'm tired down
I'm getting tired of giving white people
[ __ ] advice right how to fix their
[ __ ] right now you guys is very easy for
you to walk at any
store so a nice lift shirt on one time
I'm so tired of you grab see I can't
tell right now if you [ __ ] are
walking around kicking it or you bout to
take a [ __ ] nap or you bout to go to
bed for the difference well we got the
white man yeah I I have short arms
you're a tall guy too I'm 5 7 and my I
can never insure --ts never fit me so
everything I buy has to be taken up like
a little child my arms have to be taken
in so I find great clothes and they look
like [ __ ] them is wrong with being a
grown man in a child's body you got to
shop you just gotta shop in there see
they're not thinking about if you buy
chosen it's clothing right you put it on
you're gonna look longer
you're gonna look taller because your
[ __ ] arms gonna be longer than the
shirt of course but that's see you gotta
trick people
you gotta trick yourself to pick you
[ __ ] long and lean but you're not you
buy [ __ ] children's clothing know
there's a great taxi episode where Danny
DeVito talks about shopping in the kids
section it's like I'm a little too tall
for that timely no nothing do it man as
a guy who gives that advice you get
frustrated when people do not take it
because it seems like you have these
clear visions of like this is what this
person needs to do to be successful and
then you tell them and then you see them
just continue to fail because they don't
take your advice is that frustrating no
it's not because you look I give a rat's
ass if you take the advice right my job
it's not my job to give you advice I'm
just telling you I'm just giving good
you positive feedback on what the [ __ ]
I'm looking at you know if you don't fix
your [ __ ] you don't fix your [ __ ] but
even if I won't bring it up when I see
you again I'll look you up and down and
I'll just cut my eye a little bit and
sometimes I want to look you in the eye
I won't even look you in the [ __ ] eye
right look at your [ __ ] ear I'll look
at something else your chin yeah you
know you see son look at me why are you
staring on my [ __ ] chin but I can't
look you in the eye and not and not be
irritated true actually open for you in
Caroline's five years ago and you never
looked me in the eye so now I know why
your comic
coming there's a lot it's like there's
so many t-shirt comics yeah you almost
need to break it up
I think it's self-esteem thing caught
comics or I don't know there's so many
difficult shirts out there's a polo
comic right Nick the comic the
turtleneck comic it's gotta feel right
though whatever it has to feel
comfortable because if you're performing
something and you don't feel good in it
if you don't feel comfortable if you
feel like you're putting on like like a
kid putting on like their communion suit
yeah it doesn't feel right it doesn't if
I've worn I'll wear a suit once in a
while but it's just a little weird
seeing you in a suit now I'm gonna be
honest I'll do a little more alterations
for that [ __ ] there you are yeah
of course yeah this is what I can't
stand when I see pants and you got a
belt on and the pants and pants are a
little bit too big bundles up in the
back or on the side not that you had
your [ __ ] like that I'm just telling you
yeah in general shoulders a little bit
right you know I mean you gotta take
that [ __ ] up under the arms making sure
that all this is tight your search your
jacket your suit feel like if I get in a
fight my pants gonna rip you don't name
yeah my sleeve gonna come on that's how
I feel what about when you see that when
you see somebody wearing like a suit
jacket right but the car for the jacket
is kind of flirting right around the top
of the thumb there like it comes all the
way down to here no I feel like doing
what grabbing that [ __ ] a
headlock [ __ ] out carry a little baby
[Laughter]
yeah right yeah spin is a let's back up
in a corner slap in the [ __ ] face
water in his face and wake the [ __ ] up
right and like wow what happened and let
him be fixed right and then if that is
how like that makeover show you know the
makeover so please take queer I fixed
your [ __ ] house Extreme Makeover
people need yeah yeah once in a while
you should be able to stop somebody you
know took this out and fixed a life
little make up you unconscious though
you're almost like the Bill Cosby in
fashion right not come out people gonna
notice that shape you'll hug them like
you love me what's up man good to see
you
you just put your hand you're great you
grab that rope on the back you beat your
arm around and just talk the [ __ ] out
but it's essential to the plan that they
are unconscious when the changes are
made
[ __ ] you wouldn't cooperate
all right that makes sense they took us
out slow what did you book about the
book of Leon philosophy of a fool JB's
book is out now
no yet the book this book is uh it's
based on my character from curb the
enthusiasm that's what it's called the
book of Leon my character on curb is
Leon black you know it's called the
philosophy of a fool and this was a
finance book Jim Jim tell you you know I
was gonna write a Jimmy smooth book you
know it didn't I was talking to Larry on
set and I said you know what I'm writing
a book he said yeah I heard you're
writing a book he said you should write
a book
you know you know and I said you know
I'm writing a j.b smoove book he said um
I mean you should write a Leon book I
said I said you know writing a JB smooth
book because you know I don't own the
character but um
the cool thing is about it was he told
me he said oh no you should definitely
write that JB some move
you should write early on book JB
because you know people love Leon and he
you know I think it's a good Lane you
know and I thought about it initially
but I didn't think I could do it because
I don't want the character if I go on
you know you got to go through so much
sure calling this y'all they're doing
all this [ __ ] leg work trying to get
approvals and just got too messy and I
didn't like dealing with it so once
Larry told me I should you know I went
ahead and worked it out with HBO and um
and I want to and I thought it would be
great because it would coincide with the
new season of curb mm-hmm and the book
came out October 1st October 11th the
book came out curb came out October 1st
so you know perfect fun book man you
know I just wanted something comical
something silly and I'm and I based it I
really kept it contained within the
character
let me ask because I was going through
the book and I saw that there was like a
lot of advice for how to handle women
and hookups and things like that and I
was thinking to myself this is very
convenient because JB is a married man
so maybe some of the advice that he gave
about finding women you would really be
able to put out there with with without
your wife taking exception to it but
Leon on the other hand
so investment that's why I wrote the
book you know cuz you know I wanted the
reader to feel like they were Larry I'm
told me the dumb as a Larry so is
written in a very first first
perspective kind of way so you know when
I'm when I'm getting in Larry's ass you
know this book allows me to get in your
ways do you worry that and I I
appreciate that but do you worry that uh
that as popular as the show is and now
that the book is coming out people are
gonna start going your stand-up shows
and they're gonna want Leon right place
oh man
tell me I love you notice from that but
I've been on that show for four seasons
you know I've been doing stand-up for 30
years and people come to the show all
the time they know that you know they're
not gonna come to the show I see [ __ ]
Leon didn't come to the source you got
him JB smooth and I think you know I'm
just I think it's a character that's
already kind of grounded within this
show you know of course the first three
seasons I was just a guest but now I'm
part of the cast officially but people
people know they know that you know but
that's it that's the fun part about
being a stand-up you know you get the
chance to take people someplace they're
not used to going you know but that does
not stop them from loving the character
does not stop them from you know being
entertained or you know and I think you
know of course is curb there is but
that's not the only thing I've ever done
so I'm not like a guy who's kind of
stuck you know I do with so many things
that uh that we can do as comedians that
I think people who you know forget about
you know we do we all do
voiceover commercials we all do okay I
do network TV
I do late-night all the time I do I'm
always promoting something I'm always
doing stuff always through a bunch of
[ __ ] against the wall and see what
sticks in there so you know and I'll
take that
you know those blessings and roll with
them because I think that's what makes
us unique we all you know we all can do
very something very unique in our own
with your a while when you were doing
gigs and stuff were you like either this
mainstream success is never gonna happen
do you start to feel that way after a
certain time I never think you always
believe it but I don't never think about
stupid ass obstacles that has never been
in my DNA I never think about what the
[ __ ] is is gonna hold me back or where
I'm going I just try to go and just give
like 20% through every it could be some
minor but at the same time I police
myself you know I mean I don't I don't
take everything I don't you know I feel
like you know you should only take [ __ ]
you know money can come anytime but you
should only take [ __ ] that you're gonna
be able to put 20% in you wanna be able
to shine in because when you shine it
one thing you maybe get paid minimal
amount of money that debt that shine is
gonna be worth more than that [ __ ]
money that's gonna apply the last three
months you know I mean yeah so I I think
about long term I don't think about the
immediate I don't step on toes I don't
burn bridges I just kind of do what the
[ __ ] JB do right and I think that's some
really authentic about that and you can
sleep better at night knowing that you
know if your producer Jim you got a
[ __ ] movie you've been writing this
movie for all your [ __ ] life 20 years
trying to get this goddamn movie done
you hire me to be in the [ __ ] movie
and I show up at a half acid yeah I give
you 30% do you like this [ __ ] do is
[ __ ] my dream up now I'm [ __ ] your
dream up that you already had your mind
15 20 years you wrote this damn swing
and I saw up half-assing yo-yos enough
that's not fair to you do you know
Patrice said that he was teeth done a
project and he had written something or
it was his his thing and there was a guy
kind of being a dick Constance and
Patrice have changed me because that's
what I was he said I realized when it
was my thing in some [ __ ] up that was
it changed his opinion on things after
he saw a guy doing to his it happens man
I realize you you are you have asked and
someone else's dream right so I turn I
turn way more stuff down then I take
because I just feel like if I'm gonna
show up there just because it doesn't
know Sesame being here you know because
you know you're not gonna do it I want
to do it justice and someone else can
get that blessing someone else can do
this I even recommend somebody to do it
that way at least of
- someone who I think is very talented
can do it what about show up just for
the money you know that's never been me
man so and and that's why I think
there's something really cool about cuz
we we are comedians right at the same
time we we run a brand that we represent
on stage and we got it we got a brand
ourselves and whatever the hell we do
really well that's what people are gonna
call us about they don't cause just
because it cost because hey Jim is a bad
[ __ ] man I would love to see him
play this role and I'm so sorry you got
stabbed and got them power
thank you I'm a Misha where thank you
that was really that was a good one hi I
enjoyed the way to season good I'm
telling you man you that role you when I
first saw you in that role I said god
dammit you know me I clap because I want
my god I want everybody to win yeah
oh I want my guys to [ __ ] win because
I just know that you know this this this
stand-up [ __ ] is just a vehicle that's
all the [ __ ] it is man I doubt anybody
wants to be a 7580 old man still on
stage and some smoky ass club you know I
mean this [ __ ] still I doubt it I
want to get somewhere and and you know
and seeing everybody doing cool [ __ ]
that's what makes all this worth while
doing the doing gigs I still want to do
I always want to do gigs but you don't
want to do them in a smoky Club where
you're anonymous you don't want to do
them we're not going in and like
fighting to tell the audience look I'm
fun I'm going hey your name is on the
ticket [ __ ] we like this I wanna do that
I promise you you don't wanna do that
[ __ ] forever that's it will [ __ ] kill
you before anything for courses for
course I love that show and you had me
on twice no man you were great too much
fun that um you know sometimes you do
these projects man data we did four good
seasons of that show man it's fun we we
may even try to acquire it because we we
shot it evergreen so we is no current
events in there nothing and they all we
talk about is real [ __ ] that we go
through our lives I love everything we
we love to talk about you know as little
people because people get a chance to
see you be
and what sadly behind the comedian yeah
who the [ __ ] are you you know I mean we
tell jokes but who the [ __ ] are you and
I think I so did a great job we did a
great job with that show putting them
together I'm mixing and matching people
we put some great people together we had
a great table man that day we had the
one that was weird was through it was
you me Todd Barry Gilbert Godfrey Neil
deGrasse Tyson and Gerry Cooney Jesus
Neil deGrasse Tyson oh my god that dude
was so deep man and we was I mean we
asked this guy [ __ ] that the normal do
would ask you know yeah just we went in
on him man because anything about
science always intrigues me even Gerry
Cooney it's weird to hear like the
usually the boxers are the best guys at
the table yeah they're the best stories
the ball players the athletes but when a
guy like that like an astrophysicist
then everybody just wants to ask [ __ ]
child questions right dinosaurs and [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] real you doubt you guys
asked if dinosaurs were right in that do
you do I just like that keeps you
entertained this [ __ ] dinosaur looking
animals around but they're small right
you know I'm like wait a [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] happened right it's impossible
that we evolved into bigger people I
don't [ __ ] know what happen oh [ __ ]
so you're saying that like we're not
tiny yes same size we've always been so
I can alligator is the size of a
dinosaur but we grew we were [ __ ]
tiny well that's great [ __ ] dumbass
question but I had to ask the man I had
him at the table I had to get that [ __ ]
on my head without nowhere some [ __ ]
do students on his goddamn TV you
[ __ ] cheat it was or some [ __ ] like
that
wondering the same for me my affection
for his demands but then again what'd he
say no because you look at the bones and
those are the sighs we stand next to
them and we're still smaller there's
somebody I've heard that how about the
flat earthers there was a guy who was
just gonna take off in a rocket we don't
know why he thinks he's gonna go higher
than a plane but he said he was gonna
take off in a rocket a rocket look down
the face rocket yeah he's gonna check
for sure and I think just don't believe
[ __ ] myself you
his guys risk he's gonna risk dying this
to make sure the earth is not flat yeah
yeah I don't know what the advantage to
that is though like who's lying about
the earth being flat right well that's
the next you know me that's the next
earth wasn't flat if the earth was flat
that kinda would eliminate gravity and
and it's like how the [ __ ] do you you
know what's under the earth is flat what
the [ __ ] on the other side right just
plain this is nothing on relief and can
you get to the edge and grab ahold and
look under the mixture a should
underneath it what the [ __ ] is under it
if it's flat that's what's on I figure
out what the bottom of [ __ ] earth I
think I heard of China the Flat Earth
theory was just like that there was
there was nothing that we were there was
nothing under Flat Earth but that
there's pits right mm-hmm
there's pit so earth goes deep right but
it's not round so how the [ __ ] do you
explain the moon you see that [ __ ] every
night what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] doing
and where's it going it what [ __ ] does
it go in at night because it goes do
they go it right huh it's a moon putting
the Sun in the pocket and just like and
then where the [ __ ] is the moon and his
son going if the world is [ __ ] flat
[ __ ] they do maybe they just go up and
down they go
doing this like a pendulum can you fish
it could be too good he's a good point
that's a good guy pinpoint what the [ __ ]
does the damps moon and his son go and
can you roll it and can you go and peek
over the edge and look under the earth
and earth and peek under it right
underneath the earth is if it is flat do
you think there's the aliens are real
[ __ ] you really real cuz Neil deGrasse
Tyson comes in here and he will not
comment because there's not enough
scientific I'm gonna comment you don't
end up dead right no good is if they did
power you know how many Sciences
disappear all the time you see these
cities got their movies do you think
that there are they're covering up are
they covering it up I think there's
definitely I think I think this has to
be evidence that some [ __ ] is not
just to taste man it's impossible to
have this vast galaxy that we have out
there and there's no other outside life
you know I mean but see there goes the
balance between science and religion and
that becomes a whole different story
because you know there's evolution and
then there's religion there's so many
different you know you can go any
direction you believe in right but there
is argument for both you know me you
know but you'll also realize there are
also people who believe who believed in
the Sun gods the people who believe it's
so so many went through god of wind
there's so many different things that
through history and all of my eyes when
I went to uh I went to beliefs and we
went on tour we saw all the ruins you
know the - the Mayan ruins you know out
near Guatemala so this is amazing
because you know the - a guy he showed
us all kind of cool [ __ ] so all I'm
saying is this there is a balance
between science and but people also can
see science and also believe believe in
something bigger than that and right so
there was this he showed us a ruin and
he told us how the Emperor's were trick
kind of trick to the people the
followers you know they would they would
pop up in one part of the of the ruin of
the temple like in the middle and then
they would you know wait you know it
would almost feel like they're the ones
who caused this Sun to come out you know
all right as any would go back in and
then it will appear it's a staircase on
the back of that [ __ ] so live a run up
the stairs and get it to the very top
[Laughter]
that's how that is power what control
people with just something that coming
it's gonna happen every day can you
imagine if you could take credit for the
Sun if you really get laid schedule
can't [ __ ] around oversleep
yeah
we'll kill you the fraud or somebody
else would just run up and steal it yeah
he's got it how do you explain a cloudy
day no that's why I'm telling you you
know like we [ __ ] up and you start
mixing science and religion right you
see
right Apocalypto about the Mayan did you
see that yeah Mel Gibson phenomenal
movie the top of that [ __ ] temple
they just lop in heads off in the crazy
yeah sometimes things start very minimal
and all of a sudden they become folklore
to become whatever they want it to be
you start cutting heads off you start
sacrificing [ __ ] it's some [ __ ]
just they started out very small you
know maybe somebody killed the [ __ ]
grasshopper if you know they started
cutting off grasshoppers heads and they
say no it's not cutting off people's
heads from grasshoppers to [ __ ]
losers right [ __ ] goats whatever it
is right but that [ __ ] in the beer
people's dishonest fun
point down it just goes down one step
it's not but a person's head bounces the
whole way down so what happened you're
on your RV we were talking about that
the other day Bobby's doing fine you
still use it I told I returned you guys
all to this [ __ ] if you guys have not
experienced the RV life yet very
surprised you guys have not ventured
into that world yet I want to get it I
want to go into an ivory I thought I
really did a good selling job to you
guys how amazing it is it's expensive
though are they hard to drive it's a
great investment though are they hard to
drive like on the highway it's it's a
lot of machinery some if you can't drive
for [ __ ] already you should not be in
our RV all right I can join you got to
know how tall it is about all right I'm
telling you that [ __ ]
yeah if you don't know the [ __ ] you
doing don't think you have a big-ass RV
and get hungry and put them to
McDonald's drive-thru yeah when's the
last time you're in yours oh I put it
away
you know most time you know right now in
California is the it's about to be the
rainy season and
but I had it out all summer minute oh
man kicked it man
next time you were in LA I'm gonna keep
telling you Jim for you my friend
you know you guys okay I don't know you
guys you know I don't know how you guys
carry your lives right [ __ ] bow hung
around Jim so Jim if you ever in LA give
me a call man I'll pull the RV out any
[ __ ] time I really want to see the RV
Barbara kick up a little bit I know a
great little hotel out there man it has
an amazing bar I pull that [ __ ]
up they know me already they'll watch my
[ __ ] keep it out front we're going to
have a drink chicken man talk some [ __ ]
to each other get back in it and drive
the [ __ ] home bro hey had the wildfires
by affecting you at all don't know yeah
even with even if your house is not in
the line of fire
you know it still affects you because
you got a lot of friends out there right
you know you got to travel you know even
where I live at those fires man I mean
I've been I've been dealing with that
for 10 11 years I've been there we
there's always fires it's just this fire
just have some be one of the biggest
this one is worse just this is worse and
it came at a time when when I left LA to
come here on on Monday on Sunday it was
already 80 per 70 80 mile-per-hour winds
already so when it's that windy when I
tell you that wind is called the Santa
called the Santa Ana winds so if you
kissed that number one even without fire
you know you go in your backyard and all
your [ __ ] is against the fence you know
everything all your [ __ ] is just pushed
against the fence because it winds it
too strong
now imagine that with a fire right so
here's the problem we [ __ ] got in LA
see the rainy season the rainy season in
LA is I think February March April right
so this year we had so much rain it was
so bad I mean flooding everywhere so
what happens is it rains so [ __ ] bad
that the vegetation grows all that all
that [ __ ] in the mountains grows out of
control right then you get the
summertime there's over 100 [ __ ]
degrees every goddamn day that shit's
Raisa
[ __ ] up yeah now it's all dried up right
and you sitting there waiting for you so
you know what this ain't gonna be good
you see how tall I got
DRI is [ __ ] rot and you sitting there
like this is gonna be a problem and then
all of a sudden get a fire like this now
here's the double whammy
all that [ __ ] burned up right it burned
up all the way from freaking the whole
Ventura Valley is [ __ ] up right now
this is terrible people losing houses
pets all kind of [ __ ] you just [ __ ] up
so here's the double whammy all that
burns away right now the mountains the
valleys have nothing to hold the dirt in
place uh-huh see what happens so now the
rainy season is about to come again so
now you're gonna have mudslides off
[ __ ] rainy season yeah it can't hold
there's nothing to hold it up against
them yeah just the hill so this this is
a fucked-up part wow the fires are
really scary bit don't think you have
fire fighters like some kind of a
blanket or something like to lay under
if they get caught out in it and again
it kind of will blow over you III think
that they've been guys survived doing
that anything because they are so used I
got to give a shout-out to those guys
man fighting that fire because they do
so much so much work man is really is
tedious it's hard they have to battle
the winter win is what's killing it I
didn't it's 70 mile an hour winds
oh that's how it blows and it sprays man
and what happens in my area even though
I live 5 15 minutes away from that area
at night all we see in the distance is
the red flames yeah and then in the
morning your car is covered in ashes you
know the air quality is bad and you all
you do is some breathing and you're
smelling smoke scary is that because you
know you're watching people's houses
burned like that's [ __ ] scary it's
like you know somebody's whole life is
Christopher Lloyd said his house burned
a couple years ago he lost it ever all
these mementos and things you've built
up and moving Robson Wells your whole
life living somewhere with all you keep
thinking about is the next big
earthquake and the [ __ ] fire comes
you know it's like [ __ ] yeah yeah got
the rice you get earthquakes
you got mudslides you know all this [ __ ]
going on you're sitting there like one
of these one is three it's gonna get the
evils were gonna get me at some point
you know you don't forget ms-13 that's
true you grew up in Mount Vernon
your money on your mom burners right do
you find Westchester to be the best
Chester of course it is that's right
right I try to tell people this all time
from in New Rochelle you good not right
that's right yeah all the time
yeah yeah what see you guys at the high
school the high school football team
yeah right I tell Troy that West Chester
is the best Chester and he doesn't he's
like I don't nobody says they don't know
the [ __ ] not is did you have high school
pride or now of course man we we talk
about a big rivalry we are neighbors and
we are that's our biggest rival yeah
gonna row go again fleur-de-lis oh we
got that that is like the thing the
purple and the white florally yeah we're
the fighting Knights man we doing
Knights it's better than you I forget
what North Brunswick New Jersey's mascot
was can you look that up real quick we
had to rap with JV Travis was telling me
my ear I guess you have other places to
go he's promoting the book of Leon which
has been out since October the first I
think yeah man and philosophy of a fool
which is of course based on his
character Leon yeah I mean all you guys
we just got the book yeah this book is
so fun it's a it's a good time to laugh
man I think you know there's a great
curve season man great show oh no I
don't I don't think so because I think
what people love about Leon and they
love about curb is the interaction
between Larry and Leon that's what makes
this show work you know of course me I
can interact with anybody but it's
something about Larry and Leon that's
that's kind of Ashton stone right now
and uh you know amongst all these
amazing TV shows man and I'm just happy
I got a chance to work with Larry and um
it was my favorite show before I got on
the show so I don't think I I think I
think I think it's very easy to ruin a
character and it's very easy to you know
I think that's why you know I think I
think Larry also hates a spin-off so
also but I don't think I think I think
there's enough of curb locked in right
now you know if he decides to come back
again gotta be great but I don't think
Leon spin-off is you know I just think
that it's overkill I think
the character fun thing about Leon is
those small bites of fun yeah yeah
that's what makes the show genuine and I
think it's easy easier to remember these
small moments of a character than the
overkill yeah it's like after mash when
they try doing after mash with the
cashiers you start to really so you get
greedy and you start to try to get more
mileage out of stuff you really don't
need yeah you don't need to know a
biggest best to have a character kind of
be memorable and yeah that way like man
you know that Larry Leon had a great run
you know successful you give you know
you have your brilliant comic but you
have such a smart way of looking at this
stuff it's really practical don't be
greedy don't ever be afraid of saying
[ __ ] no right then on me